[موسيقى]
اول شغله لازم نعرفها ان الصخور كتير مهم
برمضان ليش لانه بيعطينا احساس بالشبع
وبيعطينا طاقه اثنين بخفف من الاصابه
بهبوط السكر ثلاثه بيبعد عنا الصداع او
التع
دي كثير مهم صخور ناخذه قبل ثلاث ساعات من
النوم لانه في ناس كتير ممكن تاكل وتنام
بصير معها يا اما امساك يا اما اسهال يا
اما غازات او مشاكل هضميه مشان هيك ضروري
ناخذها قبل ثلاث قبل ثلاث ساعات من النوم
شغله كمان لازم نعرفها انه نحته اذا فوتنا
السحور يا ترى بننحف ابدا هذا الموضوع
مانو صحيح ليش لانه نحن لما ما بناخذ
الصخور بصير في عنا خلل بالنظام التمثيل
الغذائي مما يؤدي الى تبطيء عمليه الهضم
او الايض بالجسم او الحرق مشان هيك ضروري
نحن ناخذ وجبه السحور شو هي الاطعمه اللي
ممكن نحن ناخذها وتمدنا بالطاقه وتخلينا
كمان نخسر وزن اهم شيء فيهم هي البقوليات
لانه فيها الياف بتساعدنا على الهضم
وبتحسسنا بالشبع لفتره طويله اثنين التمر
لانه في ثلاث انواع من السكر اللي كمان
بتحافظ على منسوب السكر بالدم 3 اكيد
الفواكه والخضار اللي بتحتوي على عدد
فيتامينات كمان بتعطينا طاقه وبتحسسها
بالشبع لفتره اطول
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات